i have to bring up the free britney
campaign
seriously i do that's actually an
important political issue britney spears
has been under a the singer has been
under a conservative ship
for quite some time now where her father
is basically controlling her life
and she has just spoken to a judge she
said i'm not happy i can't sleep i'm
depressed i cry every day
i was told right now in the
conservatorship i'm not able to get
married or have a baby so
she has a birth control device called an
iud inside of her prevents her from
getting pregnant
and uh she wants it to be removed and
her father will not let it be removed
this is truly evil stuff
this is the kind of sick stuff that you
you hear about in the eugenics movement
which you hear about from a century ago
the this is the stuff you hear about out
of communist china
if practically speaking forced
sterilization
very very evil people this should if
it's not a crime already this should be
a crime and the people who are forcing
this sort of contraception on her should
should face criminal penalties for it in
a just world
i ordinary i don't really know very much
about britney spears and i'm not saying
that conservative ships are always
illegitimate but in this case this is
obviously going too far evil evil stuff
and we actually
should as conservatives we should call
attention to it forced
sterilization whether it's permanent or
or just effectively permanent she can't
take it out that is some really really
evil stuff
hey i'm glad you like that clip we got a
whole show the title is using
government for good you can get that
whole show right here on youtube
or at apple podcast it's your google
play on the audio side
you can also order my new book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds and i want you
right now before you leave to let me
know what you think
of all those things any of those things
the book the audio podcast or this video
or just about the weather today what you
think about the weather leave a comment
right now on this video we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you